foreign
like adults is your sense of fun mostly
done a new poll finds that 27 is the
average age adults say they lost their
sense of fun yeah
sad yeah especially if your idea of
laughs is dating Leonardo DiCaprio
and over half of adults miss the sense
of fun they had when they were kids
people said they remember starting the
day feeling happy and playful and
optimistic as children but now they're
tired anxious and stressed out but still
many said they've taken part in
childlike activities since becoming an
adult including daytime naps video games
and coloring books and refusing to pay
their bills
hey it's been working out great for this
guy
but these whiners are ignoring all the
things adults get to do that kids don't
like stay up late watch R-rated movies
and vacation at Epstein Island
that's what I was looking for
okay Charlie uh so this is obviously
this is a true thing I think but is it
that people are becoming less like kids
or the fact that we're just more
tolerant of the fact that people stay
children a lot longer
oh that's definitely true but I mean you
know as children and I don't know what
what fun means here if they're just
talking about responsibility I mean
there's responsibility with everything
comes with everything that's fun in this
world but the idea that it's at age 27
is kind of weird to me because uh 20 a
lot of people today don't start having
kids until they're 27. I I didn't know
what fun was until I started having kids
because then because as a father you get
to revert back to their age when me and
my sons go away for a fishing weekend or
something like that they don't act like
a 50 year old I get to act like a 13
year old
and we don't bathe we don't brush our
teeth we become we become little Savages
and that's what's it's really really fun
I didn't get to do that before I was or
I didn't I didn't appreciate it before I
was 27 or before I had kids yeah it's
true Kat I can't picture
you as a kid I mean will you
did you have that if were you just a
little jaded child I'm gonna blow your
mind I had a First Communion
that I do believe that yeah uh was I
yeah I kind of was always I was always
like why do we live here there's not
enough opportunities here and my mom was
like you're three years old
I wanted to actually save my first
communion money for college and they
were like okay well
you know that's not going to help like
very much but I don't yeah I mean I I
mean I had I had a happy although jaded
childhood but I always wanted to you
know go out and uh live in New York and
I did that I want to be on cab TV
because I thought real TV was too
ambitious of a goal so like the little
TVs and the Cavs I would probably be
like one of those that was your goal
yeah in the fourth grade because I don't
want to like aim too high but
it also it does there's so many
different kinds of fun like you're
saying there's like the wholesome fun
and then there's like the fun that was
fun at the time but then later keeps you
up at night
um yeah for years
um but this was a British study which
surprised me because I thought it would
make sense in America because that's the
age that you are off your parents health
insurance yes so the Fun's over like you
better get all your broken legs and
gonorrhea out of the way
very true broken legs and gonorrhea
that's the title of your next book yeah
I'm uh maybe yours
that's the threat she knows Mafia people
but
Michael have you broken legs in
gonorrhea
they I mean this do first of all do you
believe this study do you actually have
to be more childlike uh well it's not
more child I think people are bummed out
that they have to work they're like I
thought this would be more real I
thought there'd be more birthday cake
and Santa Claus now you gotta work and
make your own fun just make time for
that right it's all about finding that
that balance and if you like I'm I you
know I work and I can't pay the bills
turn that into a game right like who's
calling now don't look at the phone is
that Visa or American Express
now we have to guess how much do we owe
them without going over and then your
buddy who looks like Hitler wins
[Music]
he does he needs to get in touch with
his kids side I think it really does but
your advice it
actually great advice to to actually
take the things that stress people out
about adulthood and you you don't have
to take them as seriously kids wouldn't
do that would they if you you know if
you have to pay your mortgage you make a
game out of it right Doctor Tom I mean
some would say seeing as I had a child
when I was 18 that my sense of fun went
in the trash with that pregnancy test
and I haven't actually reclaimed it to
date who would say that I would never
say that doctor no but you know what I
think I think I could really grasp this
increasing my childlike positivity like
the study saying to do if maybe just
maybe they would stop taking so much of
my hard-earned money through my taxes
and stop telling me that the world's
gonna end tomorrow just maybe if they
stop that I might be a little bit more
positive
yeah I I agree when I was such an
anxious child I would wake my parents up
in the middle of the night and be like I
I read I was supposed to have eight
glasses of water I only had four am I
gonna be long-term health
and they were like where did she come
from I'm like you
but they weren't the ones worrying about
the usually it's the parents bothering
the kids to take their vitamins you were
kind of stressed out about all this
stuff oh I was like am I gonna be okay
but did you read the part of the study
where they the whoever did the study
they set up a giant bed in the middle of
the subway station somewhere in London
so that adults could come and jump on
the bed yeah talk about you want to know
where you get your gonorrhea and broken
leg
yeah
I used to love to read like medical
textbooks and I spent so many times I
convinced myself I had scarlet fever
[Laughter]
every time I didn't feel good I was like
Mom like this is really dangerous like I
think I have scarlet fever I don't you
know yeah
completely normal and well adjusted so
Loftus you used to read medical texts
didn't you oh yeah yeah oh yeah up in
the attic with the flashlight absolutely
that's like so that's what you call that
and then hopefully there's a never mind
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else